foreign
it has been a very big night for new
zealanders across the country but
particularly in the upper North Island I
want to acknowledge the situation that
new zealanders have been waking up to
this morning a lot of families displaced
a lot of homes without power extensive
Damage Done across the country it will
take us a wee while to get a handle on
exactly what's happened we I want to
acknowledge those families that are
currently functioning without power and
in some cases without Communications and
we'll be working as quickly as we can
with the relevant agencies to make sure
that we're getting the power back on to
make sure we're restoring Communications
as quickly as we possibly can we'll be
aware a national state of emergency has
been declared and that means that we'll
be throwing everything at this to make
sure we're providing as much support to
the response as possible we have the
Defense Force on the ground now already
providing a lot of logistical support uh
helping with evacuations helping to keep
essential supplies moving and in due
course helping with the cleanup when we
get to that point
this doesn't compare with anything this
is just over the top
really
um
you know like the thunder and lightning
and everything last night was just
horrific so but the devastation is just
oh it just makes you makes you want to
cry to be honest very upsetting